Linux is a free operating system that
has a similar style and operation to the
older Unix operating system. Linux is an
operating system that has many different
types. We refer to these different types
as Linux distributions. For example, you
might see some Linux distributions
called Ubuntu, another one called
Debian, another one with Red Hat, and
others. One of the big advantages of the
Linux operating system is that there's
no cost to be able to install and use
this operating system. And Linux runs on
a number of different hardware
platforms. You can run Linux on a brand
new computer or you can go back a number
of years and run Linux on those older
pieces of hardware. Linux has the
flexibility to support a lot of
different types of hardware. And there
is a very passionate and very active
user community that helps support Linux
on the internet. There's obviously no
one central company that manages Linux
as an operating system. So, we do rely
on that user community for updates to
the operating system and additional
device drivers. This means you could get
a brand new computer with a new video
card and you may find that there's no
Linux device driver to be able to use
that video card. Using Linux is very
similar to almost any other operating
system. We become very accustomed to
having a desktop with icons, being able
to choose applications from a list or a
doc. And this is very similar to the
operation you might find in Windows or
Mac
OS. When you turn on your computer, it
goes through a process to be able to
start the operating system that you've
configured on the storage drive of that
computer. This means we could be running
Windows, Linux, Mac OS, or other
operating systems on this computer. But
how does the computer know how to load
that operating system? The first thing
that starts when you power on a computer
is the basic input output system or the
BIOS. The BIOS is configured with a list
of all of the storage devices connected
to your system and one of those storage
devices is configured to be the bootable
storage device. The BIOS then turns over
the boot process to that storage device
that has been marked as the boot device.
That boot device then runs a boot loader
that's usually located in the boot
sector of that boot device. It's that
bootloadader that is responsible for
then starting up the operating system
that's been installed on that storage
device. If you go into the BIOS
configuration of your device, there's
usually a section that describes the
startup sequence. This tells the BIOS
the order that should be used to try
booting an operating system from these
devices. From this list, you can specify
USB drives, optical drives, SSDs, hard
drives, and any other storage device
that may be connected to your computer.
The one that's at the top of the list
will be tried first. The one that's
second on the list will be tried second,
and so on. The type of BIOS on our
modern computers is a UEFI BIOS. This
stands for the unified extensible
firmware interface. This BIOS has the
configuration we mentioned earlier that
tells it to go to a storage drive and
begin starting the operating system. On
that storage device is an EFI system
partition or ESP. And in that partition,
we have a list of all of the EFI files
that are associated with different
operating systems on that storage drive.
For example, there might be a load A EFI
that is configured to start one OS
kernel and a load B efi that's
configured to start another OS kernel.
You're usually presented on the screen
with an option of which operating system
you'd like to start. You select the one
that you would like to begin and the
correct OS kernel will start based on
the EFI
files. This kernel is the core of the
operating system that you'll be
launching. It is the software that
manages everything else that happens
inside of that operating system. The
kernel starts the system. It loads up
any device drivers. It manages
applications that are executing. It
makes sure that system processes are
running and it interacts with you, the
end user. This kernel manages the most
important aspects of your operating
system. When you're starting your
system, it manages system processes and
it interacts with devices and other
pieces of hardware that are connected to
your computer. Because this kernel is so
important, it has its own area of memory
that it runs in. We refer to this as
kernel space. This is different than the
applications that you're running on your
computer which are running in user
space. And you will see times where you
need to upgrade the kernel of your
operating system probably because there
are new features, bug fixes, security
patches, and other important changes.
If you're familiar with Windows, then
you know when you start the Windows
operating system, there are a series of
services that load in the background of
the operating system. There's a similar
process in Linux and the software that
manages that process is systemd. These
background processes or services that
are running in Linux are referred to as
demons and systemd is responsible for
starting, stopping and managing those
demons. For example, when you start up
your Linux operating system, there needs
to be a logging process that begins and
systemd starts that process. The kernel
of your Linux operating system is
responsible for starting systemd. System
D then starts the processes necessary to
get your system running. And finally, we
have Linux up and running. System D is a
relatively new addition to the Linux
operating system. And it was created so
that we could have one consistent set of
tools to be able to start our system and
manage all of these background
demons. In the Windows operating system,
if you want to log in and have full
control over the entire operating
system, you log in as the administrator
user. In Linux, you log in as the root
user. The root user has full control of
the Linux operating system, and you can
start and manage all applications by
using the root user. This means if you
need to make changes to system files,
you need to install a new demon or do
anything else from an administrative
nature, you'll probably need to do this
with root
permissions. If you use Windows or Mac
OS, then you're aware that the graphical
user interface is an important part of
those operating systems. But in Linux,
the user interface is an optional piece
of the OS. You can run Linux completely
from the command line and be able to
control and manage any aspect of the
operating system. Most aspects of the
Linux operating system are managed from
textbased configuration files. And if
you need to make a change to the
operating system, it's as simple as
editing one of those text files. When
you add a user to a Linux system, a
number of important parameters
associated with that user are stored in
a file in the Etsy directory. And the
file name that it stores it is pass WD.
This lists all of the users on the
system along with a number of
configuration parameters such as the
username, password information, user ID,
group ID, user ID information, home
directory, and the command or shell that
you'd like to run as that user. The
first item on each of these lines is the
username. And you'll notice there are
system usernames at the top of this. And
then we have some users that are listed
down near the bottom. There's professor
and Jack and Sam and other users. You'll
notice that the second item on each line
is the letter X. That's where the
password would normally go. And if you
look at your Linux distribution, you'll
notice that your password file has X's
in it as well, where the password would
normally be. We realize that having a
single file that's able to be read by
everyone that has usernames and a hashed
version of the password leaves our
system susceptible to a brute force
attack. So, we took the passwords out of
the password file and put them into a
different file known as the shadow file.
This is also located in the Etsy
directory. And you'll notice it has the
same list of names associated with it,
but now we have a list of hashed
passwords along with the username. The
difference with the shadow file is that
it is a protected file that cannot be
viewed by other people on the system
unless they have elevated rights and
permissions. This file format is very
similar to the one you just saw with the
password file. It has a list of the
usernames. It has a password hash, the
date of the last password change, and
other parameters. It's obviously
important that this file is protected
because we don't want that password hash
to get in the hands of an attacker where
they can reverse engineer or brute force
the real password based on the hash that
is stored in the shadow file.
Another important file in your Linux
distribution is also in the Etsy
directory and the name of that file is
hosts. This is a file that associates a
fully qualified domain name or an FQDN
with an IP address. For example, it
might have an IP address of
10.110.224 and it has a fully qualified
domain name associated with that IP
address of staging.professor
messor.com. Before there was a domain
name system or DNS, this host file was
how we provided a resolution between a
name and an IP. Obviously, adding single
lines to a host file does not scale very
well, which is why we decided DNS would
be a better choice going forward. But
this host file still exists on these
systems and it does still have an
important use. If you want to override
the settings associated with DNS, you
can add the IP address and fully
qualified domain name to the host file
and anything in the host file takes
priority over the DNS
settings. Well, if we aren't going to
use the host file and we're going to use
DNS, how do we tell Linux where these
DNS servers are? To do that, we use
another file that's in your Etsy
directory called resolve.com.
This file contains a list of the DNS
servers that this Linux machine will use
for name resolution. You can look at the
resolve.com file to see what name
servers have been configured. For
example, on this device, name server
127.0.053 is the only name server listed
in the resolve.com file. If you're
troubleshooting a DNS configuration or
you want to confirm the DNS settings on
a Linux machine, then you should look at
the Etsy directory and the resolve.com
file.
Connected to your Linux device are
storage devices that have partitions and
other file systems. This means that we
need to tell our Linux operating system
where these partitions are and what type
of file system is on those partitions.
We do this using another file that's in
your Etsy directory called FS tab for
file system table. When your system
starts up, it references this file
system table to be able to mount all of
the different drives that you're using
for this Linux operating system. And if
you start your Linux distribution and
you find that a particular file or drive
is missing, it may not be listed in your
FS tab file.